was ist eigentlich kreativität sind nur
bestimmte menschen kreativ und sind sie
damit geboren oder kann man auch
kreativität lernen warum es so wichtig
ist dass unsere gesellschaft etwas
umdenkt das erfahrt ihr jetzt bei pixum
science und fiction
in einem unserer letzten videos haben
wir über das schulsystem gesprochen und
was sich in zukunft aendern wird und vor
allem auch was sich am schulsystem
ändern sollte dabei ist ganz oft das
wort kreativität gefallen
die menschen von morgen müssen nämlich
kreativer sein als ein computer
algorithmus ganz normales arbeiten nach
schema f wird dann einfach nicht mehr
funktionieren
kein wunder natürlich dass ihr dann in
den kommentaren mehr über kreativität
erfahren wollte was ist das überhaupt
wissenschaftlich gesprochen
kreativität können auch um kreative
menschen kreativität trainieren oder das
irgendwie lernen und wie bringen wir
unsere kinder dazu in der schule
kreativer zu denken
um genau diese fragen geht es jetzt also
fangen wir erstmal am anfang an was ist
eigentlich dieses kreativität
klar jeder von uns hat eine gewisse
vorstellung davon aber dieses konzept in
worte zu fassen ist gar nicht so leicht
und auch viele experten streiten sich
sogar um die genaue definition aber hier
ist eine die mir persönlich besonders
gut gefällt
kreativität ist ein prozess bei dem
ungewöhnliche oder komplett neue ideen
produziert werden die einen gewissen
wert haben hier zwei wichtige dinge
erstens kreativität ist ein prozess also
es passiert nicht von jetzt auf gleich
und verschwindet dann wieder euer gehirn
arbeitet ständig und dauerhaft an
problemen und ideen und zweitens heißt
ein gewisser werte nicht dass man damit
irgendwie geld verdienen muss oder dass
man das professionell machen muss also
zum beispiel professioneller maler sein
muss oder so etwas kreatives muss nicht
mal einen zweck haben oder besonders
sein oder besser sein als irgendetwas da
schon vorher da war aber wenn ihr selber
oder irgendjemand auf dieser welt eure
erfindungen oder was auch immer ihr
gerade kreativ produziert hat wenn er
das schön findet oder wenn ihr das
einfach nur anders findet oder
intelligent dann hat das schon einen
gewissen wert wenn auch nur für eine
person
was also kann man alles tolles
produzieren da stehen euch wirklich alle
türen offen einen witz ein bild ein
literarisches werk musik einen film
einen tanz eine bewegung eine lösung für
ein problem oder vielleicht sogar etwas
ganz abstraktes eine art zu denken oder
zu sehen ich habe keine ahnung wer kann
wirklich alles kreative produzieren das
wichtige hier ist jeder mensch ist
kreativ ohne ausnahme viele von den
studien jetzt vielleicht den kopf denn
manche menschen behaupten sie sind
einfach nicht kreativ aber das bedeutet
manchmal auch einfach nur dass die
menschen meinen dass sie nicht gut malen
können
oder was auch immer sie reden sich dann
ein dass sie deswegen nicht kreativ sind
aber die stärken eines jeden können
überall liegen
kreative menschen mal nicht nur bilder
es gibt auch kreative mathematiker
chemiker oder vielleicht sogar
historiker aber jeder von euch ist
kreativ dass der punkt also wenn jeder
von uns allen kreativ ist wie können wir
diese kreativität dann frei lassen wie
können wir die trainieren und wir können
uns das ganze zu nutze machen
nun ich habe hier mal ein kleines spiel
vorbereitet hat bei diesem spiel immer
drei wörter wie anscheinend nicht viel
miteinander zu tun haben und ihr müsst
jetzt ein wort finden das alle drei
wörter gleichzeitig miteinander
verbindet in diesem fall ist das käse
hüttenkäse käsekuchen und schweizer käse
hat herausgefunden
wenn ja dann hat euer gehirn gerade in
dem moment in dem ihr das wort heraus
gefunden habt eine komplett neue
verbindung hergestellt
eine verbindung von sachen die vorher
noch nichts miteinander zu tun hatten
und das nennt man kreativität ob das
jetzt ein wort ist oder eine idee ein
konzept was auch immer wenn man zwei
sachen miteinander nicht viel zu tun
haben oder gar nichts zu tun haben
miteinander verbindet und dadurch etwas
etwas neues schafft dann nennt man das
kreativität und ich sehe jetzt schon wie
viele von euch enttäuscht sind fällt das
rätsel gerade nicht schnell genug
herausgefunden haben
deshalb gebe ich euch jetzt hier noch
ein weiteres rätsel und ihr schreibt mir
gleich und in die kommentare was eure
lösung dazu ist kurz bevor er gehirn die
verbindung zwischen den wörtern
hergestellt hat läuft ein bestimmter
teil eures gehirns auf hochtouren
und zwar ist das euer temporallappen der
gehört zu euren großhirn befindet sich
hier hinten hinter den ohren
und der ist für genau diese aufgabe
geschaffen nämlich sachen zu erkennen
die miteinander zu vergleichen und im
zweifel auch zu verbinden
alles klar sagte jetzt wahrscheinlich
jetzt müssen wir noch diesen
temporallappen irgendwie stimulieren und
dann finden wir einfach eine sache nach
der anderen und werden stinkreich oder
ja ganz so einfach wird es
wahrscheinlich nicht da gibt es noch
keine technik für aber es gibt
möglichkeiten um euren temporallappen zu
aktivieren
dazu gehört zum beispiel entspannung
ganz einfach unter stress kommen einem
nicht so viele kreative ideen man sollte
sich selber nicht so stark unter
zeitdruck setzen denn damit fokussiert
sich euer gehirn auf das problem selber
wenn ihr euch stattdessen ein bisschen
entspannen könnte dann kann euer
temporallappen besser arbeiten und ihr
ding quasi um das pro
neben herum im neudeutschen nennt man
das auch einfach fink gegen outside of
the box wie also kann ich mich am besten
entspannen und kommen in eine art
kreative stimmung
zum einen ist natürlich schlafen
unglaublich wichtig ist klar wer müde
ist er kann nicht klar und deutlich
denken
außerdem kommen einem traum vielleicht
gute ideen oder man erinnert sich an
dinge die einem weiterhelfen können bei
der lösung des problems
übrigens eine studie nach der anderen
schwört auf die positive wirkung von
mittagsschläfchen
wenn ihr also das nächste mal eine
schreibblockade oder irgendeine andere
blockade habt legt euch einfach für eine
stunde hin
das ist nicht nur unglaublich gesund für
euren körper sondern entspannt auf euren
temporallappen und vielleicht findet ihr
dann im traum die lösung für ihr problem
der nächste tipp wird euch bestimmt gut
gefallen nämlich trinkt bier natürlich
nicht zu viel zu viel alkohol ist
natürlich immer schlecht aber in
gewissem maße kann alkohol sehr anregend
und vor allem kreativität fördern würden
wenn ihr dann nach dem wir eine zündende
idee hat und wer möchte die cdu umsetzen
dann ist uns kaffee trinken wesentlich
besser denn das steigert eure
konzentration und ihr könnt quasi die
idee die schon habt gut durchsetzen und
konzentriert daran arbeiten
und übrigens ganz wichtig kreativität
ist wie schon gesagt ein prozess ist
arbeit kein buch schreibt sich von
alleine von oben nach unten ohne dass
noch immer noch mal zu übergehen oder
auch mal durchzuarbeiten und abgesehen
von mozart kann auch keiner einen song
einfach so von oben nach unten auf
schreiben gut ich höre jetzt schon viele
von euch sagen dass man den kindern in
der schule besser kein bier für die
kreativität geben sollte und da muss ich
euch zu stimmen aber wie können wir
unser schulsystem so verbessern dass die
kinder kreativer denken
wie schaffen wir eine gesellschaft von
problemlöser von dichtern und denkern
die wissenschaft ist sich einig kinder
müssen nämlich ermutigt werden kreativ
zu denken
ein mathe problem kann immer auf mehrere
arten und weisen gelöst werden und das
sollte man natürlich auch im unterricht
verdeutlichen
außerdem ist es wichtig dass die schüler
inspiriert werden jeden tag etwas neues
und spannendes zu lernen dass ein auch
wirklich interessiert dass es extrem
wichtig damit zb der charakter eines
menschen geformt wird damit man zu
beispiel seine interessen entdeckt jeder
mensch ist individuell und es gibt
nichts individuelleres als kreativität
und genau deswegen müsst muss in der
schule auf jeden einzelnen schüler
eingegangen werden auch wenn das
zeitaufwendig ist jeder sollte die
möglichkeit bekommen seine kreativität
zu entdecken und zu beweisen
also hier eine kleine zusammenfassung
kreativität ist ein prozess jeder mensch
kann auf seine eigene art und weise
kreativ sein
die verbindung von mehreren ideen die
bisher nichts miteinander zu tun hatten
findet im temporallappen statt und um
den zu aktivieren muss man sich
entspannen und unser bildungssystem
sollte die schüler darauf vorbereiten
probleme zu lösen indem die schüler
ermutigt und inspiriert werden und in
den möglichkeiten für kreativität
geboten werden wenn ihr euch jetzt
selber inspirieren lassen wollt findet
ihr hier oben die drei besten
erfindungen gegen den klimawandel zu rap
und zum blog jetzt wie man hier unten da
gibt es mehr spannende themen und ich
bin natürlich immer auf eure meinung
gespannt was ist eurer meinung nach
kreativität und wie findet ihr die
besten ideen schreibt es mir und in die
kommentare und ansonsten sah ich wie
immer vielen dank fürs zuschauen bis zum
nächsten mal